PROFESSOR: Hydrogen atom,
the first thing to do
is to describe the
potential V or r.
And it would be in the units
that we'd like to use minus e
squared over r.
e is the charge of the electron,
and the electron and proton
with the same charge.
The potential
energy is negative.
And that sign you should
be comfortable with.
It's suggesting that you
go closer and closer.
You're going down and
energy is favored.
The two particles to go
on top of each other.
Immediately we want to
generalize it a little so
that it's hydrogen like atoms.
And we'll put a Z here, assuming
that the proton, instead
of the program, there's
a nucleus with z protons.
And there probably would
be about z electrons,
but we're worried now
about just one electron.
And in this case, a
charge in the proton
is ze multiplied by the charge
of the electron gives you
this as the potential energy.
And this is advantageous.
You sometimes have
an alpha particle
that captures an electron,
and then there's two protons.
And you don't want
to solve this, again,
from the beginning.
So just put the z, and
that's what we will do.
So a few numbers.
We've done some of
these numbers before,
but the Bohr radius and one way
of calculating the Bohr radius
is to just think of units
and think of energy.
Energy goes like h
squared over ma squared.
This has units of energy.
You remember p squared over 2m.
And p is h over distance.
So if you have a
Bohr radius a 0,
this quantity has
units of energy.
But a potential
has units of energy
and we just put e
squared over a0.
So this is a consistent equation
between two quantities that
have units of energy
from which you
can get the unique
length that has
units of energy, which is a0.
And a0 is h squared
over me squared.
It's a very simple and nice
constant is the Bohr radius.
Intuitively one thing
that should remember,
e is appearing in
the right place.
And you could imagine if
the strength of electricity
was weaker and weaker,
like setting e going to 0,
the atom would become
bigger and bigger.
It would just not
be able to hold it.
So it's reasonable to
expect this to happen.
So at this moment,
we can calculate what
this is, at least, estimate it.
And for that, we multiply by
a c squared e squared over m--
mc squared.
And then we recall
that e is squared
over hc is about 1 over 137.
So we write this as
hc over e squared
over hc times mc squared.
Now in here what mass is
the mass that we should put.
I will not be all that careful.
It should really be
the reduced mass.
But in differs by a factor
of one part in 1,000 or less
even from the mass
of the electrons.
So I'll put just the
mass of the electron.
This it's about
197 mev for Fermi.
This is 1 over 137.
And for the electron is 0.5
times 10 to the 6 ev 0.5 mev.
I won't run the numbers.
The answer is about
0.529 angstroms,
which is about 53 picometers.
Angstrom is 10 to
the minus 10 meters.
Picometer 10 to the
minus 12 meters.
So that's a length scale
you've seen several times.
There's an energy scale
that is famous to.
And that's e squared over a0.
Because energy comes
here, the energy scale
is e squared over e0.
So you can substitute what a0
is because you know it already.
And you get e to the
fourth over m over h
squared, which is e to
the fourth over h squared
c squared times Mc squared.
And you see it's kind of nice to
see these quanities appearing,
because here you have e
squared over hc squared times
mc squared.
So the typical energy
of the hydrogen atom
is the fine-structure constant,
sometimes called alpha squared
times an energy.
And what energy's
available in the problem?
The rest energy of the electron.
So if the bound state
energy should be something,
it should be a number
proportional to the energy
that the problem already has.
And the problem has one
energy, the rest energy
of the electron.
So it's not surprising.
So it's one over 137
squared times 511,000 ev.
And that's about 27.2 ev.
And the reason this
may sound familiar
is because the true ground state
energy of the hydrogen atom
is this number divided
by 2, which is 13.6 ev.
So of course, you would
not know at this stage,
because you're
just doing numbers.
I may remind you of things did
a long time ago in this course.
You calculated a couple
of other constants.
And you showed that alpha--
again, the
fine-structure constant
comes a0 was the so-called
Compton wavelength
of the electron, with a bar.
So it's h bar over mc.
Remember, that the
Broglie wavelength
is h over the momentum.
The Compton wavelength
this h over mc.
And the Bard can wave
at the h bar over mc.
And that's what alpha
times a zero is.
And that quantity
is about 400 Fermi.
It's already much smaller
than the Bohr radius.
It's smaller by 137
from the Bohr radius.
And then if you do
alpha squared a0,
that actually was the
classical electron radius.
So you must divide
this by 137, again,
and it gives you
about 2.8 Fermi.
And what you can remember
is that the size of a proton
is about a Fermi.
So that gives you a
little bit of intuition.
So those are the basic
numbers that we begin with,
with the hydrogen atom.
It gives you a scale of what's
going on, the size of an atom,
and the energies that
we're supposed to get.